[Applaudissements]
gardant tout le monde je voudrais vous
présenter en fait aujourd'hui une amie
qui compte vraiment beaucoup pour moi
nous travaillons ensemble depuis
quelques années maintenant et elle est
vraiment très très cool quoi vous la
connaissez forcément elle habite avec sa
famille dans une petite caisse en bois
ou dans les arbres ou dans les cheminées
cet ami c'est joséphine d'alain elle est
belle hein joséphine c'est une actrice
incontournable du cycle de la vie en
voyageant de fleur en fleur et collecte
du nectar et du pollen qu'elle
travaillera et qu'elle stockera en fait
pour nourrir toute sa famille elle
participe activement en fait à la
pollinisation des fleurs et des légumes
que nous mangeons tellement que si elle
disparaissait 80% en fait des crises et
des légumes qui constitue notre
alimentation quotidienne pas dire
disparaissent et les disparités en fait
c'est une bosseuse
en une petite heure et un voyage et peut
visiter environ 700 fleurs en israël en
fait ça fait onze fleurs 20 minutes
c'est complètement assez hallucinant
quoi je rappelle kevin et les moines à
besson et je suis apiculteurs j'élève
des abeilles depuis quelques années
maintenant et passé par mois parce que
j'adore le miel qui n'aime pas ça mais
parce que en fait je tenais vraiment à
mouler en fait de cette petite bête quoi
j'ai eu la chance de grandir dans une
petite famille d'agriculteurs du côté de
phare nous faisions pousser des tomates
des salades du manioc etc nous
cultivions la terre et ça a développé
chez moi une certaine passion pour tout
ce qui touche de près ou de loin à la
nature donc je vais je me suis intéressé
à des techniques de culture
traditionnelle mais également à la
permaculture à la coop honni et un peu
plus tard naturellement l apiculture
je me suis également plus de patients en
fait depuis depuis mon plus jeune âge
pour l'informatique et pour
l'électronique n'avions pas vraiment
beaucoup de moyens à l'époque
et en fait j'ai récupéré des appareils
au bord de la route bien des amis ou de
la famille à la déchetterie je les
démonter pour essayer de comprendre
comment est-ce qu'il fonctionnait à
l'intérieur et je vais modifier gelé
départ et je faisais des petits robots
et au démontage quoi parfois je démonte
et même les jouets de mes frères et
soeurs en cachette vous laisser décupler
les moteurs et les lettres comme il faut
pas le dire quoi mais revenons à
joséphine mon ami avec quoi en fait j'ai
retrouvé chez elle des valeurs qui me
sont chères
l'humilité la patience le respect
lorsque l'on s'intéresse en fait à cette
petite bête à ces petites abeilles on se
rend compte qu'elle est capable en fait
de tout un tas de plus insoupçonnés
géolocalisation prise des décisions
c'est une démocratie parfaite en fait
dans la rue chemin et elle est capable
également de faire des acrobaties
incroyables dans léa c'est un truc de
fou
hallucinant et puis ce jeu crazy plus
elle mais tony mais au fur et à mesure
de mes recherches en fait j'ai fini par
découvrir qu'elle était quand même
vachement fragile cette petite vêtements
c'est à cette liste vous le savez
peut-être des gens mais les populations
d'abeilles décline à travers le monde où
tout un tas de raisons assez complexe
qu'on ne comprend pas forcément
aujourd'hui les populations décline sous
les actions de l'homme et du célé
chimiques changement climatique
déforestation monoculture parasites et
c'était avant tout un tas de choses qui
peuvent malheureusement faire du mal à
cette petite bêtement les abeilles sont
fragiles mais en fait c'est toute la
biodiversité qui déclinent sous les
accents de l'homme je me suis donc
demandé en fait ce que je pouvais faire
moins à mon niveau à mon échelle pour
essayer de proposer une solution à ce
problème
et puis c'était aussi pour moi le moyen
en fait de pouvoir conjuguer mon amour
pour la nature et ma passion pour la
technique
je voulais comprendre ce qui se passait
en fait dans la ruche je voulais en
apprendre de plus en plus si cette
petite abeille
et puis je creuse et que je voulais
entreprendre plus qu'on fait ça fait
beaucoup de plus comme tient tenez par
exemple saviez-vous que les abeilles
avec la climatisation et le chauffage
dans la ruche c'est quand même en tout
confort quoi j'ai même pas ça chez moi
on fait quoi tout comme un corps humain
qui est maintenu à 37 degrés en bonne
santé
joséphine et ses copines fait un gros
travail en fait pour maintenir la
température entre 35 et 36 degrés
celsius c'est la température idéale pour
élever les jeunes abeilles pour se
chauffer en fait elle se frotte les unes
aux autres et activent leurs muscles
pour se rafraîchir
elle bat des ailes pour créer un courant
d'air et ventiler la ruche et ça mes
amis c'est exactement le genre
d'information que l'on peut mesurer avec
des capteurs j'ai donc développé en fait
des outils des capteurs c'est le petit
truc orange que vous voyez là vous me
direz différentes informations sur la
colonie d'abeilles la température
l'humidité
l'activité des abeilles le poids etc et
toutes ces informations nous
l'enseignant fait sur leur état de santé
leur comportement ou tout simplement sur
la production de miel
toutes ces informations ont fait que
l'on collecte ne permet d'être beaucoup
plus proche de nos abeilles est solide
et longer en plus alors en fait j'ai
développé une balance par exemple cette
balance elle est installée sous la ruche
est tamisée elle permet de mesurer son
point bas au csc concept même du balance
de mesurer son poids
merci nous avons appris quelque chose
que les lignes quoi mais en fait en
développant cette balance ben figurez
vous que j'ai at-il quelque chose quoi
j'ai appris que les abeilles pouvez
consommer jusqu'à 2 kg de miel en une
semaine de pluie comment une si petite
bête en fait peut avaler deux kilos de
miel en une semaine de plus classique et
du coup en fait j'ai adapté mais
pratique pour respecter ce besoin en
nourriture
j'anticipe je collecte moins de miel et
je laisse beaucoup plus pour les
abeilles
et voilà exactement en fait comment la
technologie peut contribuer à la
préservation des abeilles et de la
biodiversité
elle nous permet de mesurer de collecter
des informations
ces informations nous l'enseignent en
fait sur comment fonctionne tout ce
petit monde
comment fonctionne cette mécanique
complexe comment elle vit cette petite
abeille
comment fonctionne toute la colonie et
comment est-ce qu'elle interagit avec
son environnement ses outils techniques
nous développant nous permet d'avoir une
gestion plus durable plus responsable et
plus respectueuse des abbayes dans mon
cas j'ai adapté la technique la
technologie à la problématique que je
connaissais des abbés quoi celle qui met
touché par un personnel pourquoi
mais en fait ces outils techniques sont
complètement flexibles on pourrait les
appeler les appliquer à d'autres
problématiques de la surveillance des
océans par exemple à la gestion des
espaces de culture
ces outils peuvent s'adapter pour
répondre à ces problématiques la cua la
technologie c'est le moyen que j'ai
trouvé moi personnellement pour résoudre
ce problème mais en fait chacun d'eux
pour chacun d'entre vous vous vous aussi
vous pouvez contribuer à la préservation
des abeilles et de la nature quoi et ça
ça passe par des gestes très très simple
tout d'abord planté ce après les bêtes
comme ça mais planté planté en fait d
essence qui pourront fournir du nectar
et du pollen de la nourriture pour les
abeilles et les pollinisateurs qui sait
peut-être que vous aussi vous allez
pouvoir voir je vous ai fini ses copines
débattez dans votre jardin ou sur votre
balcon toi ça c'est cool ça c'est cool
quoi faut savoir que les avait aussi un
besoin de beaucoup d'eau elles ont
besoin pour élever les jeunes larves les
oeufs et les jeunes abeilles de la ruche
quoi et comme je l'aï dit à l'heure pour
de la fesci et la russie et vous l'avez
vous les avez peut-être vu en fait dans
vos piscines ou sur des flaques d'eau
pour essayer de collecter un peu de quoi
en disposant des abreuvoirs voulez la
paix mettez en fait d'avoir accès à de
l'eau propre sans pesticides ni produits
chimiques
ça passe ça fait tout simple une petite
assiette avec des cailloux à l'intérieur
des petites pierres
pour éviter qu'elles puissent enfin pour
faire en sorte qu'elle puisse se poser
tranquillement suffira largement quoi
enfin je voudrais vous vous proposez en
fait de plutôt favorisé le miel local
il faut savoir que certaines maladies
qui touchent aujourd'hui les abeilles et
les pollinisateurs peuvent voyager à
travers le miel donc c'est le cas de la
loupe par exemple quoi en favorisant le
miel local
vous participez activement à la
préservation des abeilles et la
biodiversité et voulait compenser le
travail de l'apiculteur voyez c'est des
gestes très simples en fait quoi pour
conclure je voudrais juste vous dire que
pour faire un petit coup à la vidéo de
tout à l'heure la technologie en fait
n'est qu'un outil comme les votre
smartphone ou comme les internet par
exemple quoi mais la préservation de
tous
enfin la préservation de la biodiversité
et de la nature
c'est la fête de tous et on peut tous
contribué vous faire en sorte de laisser
des mots enfin un monde beau naturel
planté est vert et c'était là pour nos
enfants nos petits-enfants c'est notre
responsabilité à tous et c'est comme ça
que je voudrais conclure ma présentation
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]